everybody packed in let me properly
introduce our guests okay so this is
alex hermozy from gym launch okay so
listen to me guys this is
the all-time biggest internet marketer
for fit
fitness there ever was okay so i'm going
to share my screen in just a second here
and um you guys have heard me say this
my one of my all-time favorite
entrepreneurs is russell brunson from
clickfunnels
russell brunson calls alex hermosie the
best sales guy
that he knows he said to you one time
on a vlog okay so this is a big dude
i just said this not too long ago i ran
into a situation being
uh six months ago i was feeling a little
caved in
somebody said some stuff a couple pieces
of some stuff i'm like yo
alex i'm facing this dude what are your
you know
like what's your opinion and you
basically told me what i kind of knew
which was like dude it don't matter what
people say about you matters what you
say about you
and if there's a little truth of what
they're saying that's when it hurts
so if you know like what you're doing
what you stand for none of that [ __ ]
matters
and dude i snapped out of it okay so you
guys know you know some of the stuff
i've been able to achieve
oh yeah this is a guy that i'm like dude
this is like a big bro
this guy right here is the real deal and
he's here today
he had a surgery and he's like mike
whatever i can do to you know support
the community drop some gems inspire
like i'm here
i got a presentation if not i'm gonna
share my story whatever you need i'm
here
so um alex or mosey for gym launch these
are 25 million dollar plaques
the one thing let me give you the
updated one let me give you the updated
one bro i got
i got all four i got all four i got all
four bro 100 million dollars fourth one
this is the michael jackson usually they
said the michael jordan but these are
like flats
this is michael jackson of internet
marketing guys
big freaking deal so alex from gym lost
bro welcome man good to see you
either way um alex becker who's the
who's the founder of that
uh clued me in recently to something
he's like dude your
your your roads is insane because he can
see everyone's revenue and their ad
spend
and i was like oh what do you mean he's
like you have the highest return on ad
spend of everyone in the entire platform
by like a mile and i didn't really ever
think about it but
our lifetime return on advertising is 36
to 1.
so to do over you know 100 and
now you know 5 or 10 million whatever
we're at now
we've spent just under 3 million dollars
in advertising
and so there's a lot of other pieces to
you know making more
but just for everyone on this call we're
talking specifically about sales correct
yes so alex yeah yeah 99
of these guys are closers and they're
getting closing positions a couple
people are starting like a closer agency
where they partner with a guy like you
and they're like hey let's do like a
little jb deal
icelander deals okay sweet
well then why don't i so what i'm going
to do is because i do have a
presentation
um which is just how i think about sales
and i have the third part of the
presentation about scaling sales teams
does anyone here have multiple closures
to work for them
or is is most people just closing on
your own right now
you guys got to talk with alex you don't
bite i also can't
i can't see the chat i can't see the
chat we're working towards that alex
okay so how about this i'll give you the
things that so
um russell when i first met him was like
dude how did you learn how to sell so
well and
it was because i looked at my crm and
i'd done 4 000 sales
one-on-one uh in fitness and so
that's a lot of reps you know i was
taking 20 consults a day for like four
years
and so that's in person face to face my
team would double the triple book me
every 30 minutes
and i just sold the same thing over and
over again and because i was really good
at sales
i ended up not hiring a ton of sales
people and i would actually have my
managers set appointments for me
all at one location so i had six gyms
and so i would go there they'd stack up
an entire day
i'd mow down a whole day go to a
different gym and they'd been stacking
all the appointments and i'd mow down
and so usually i do 20 to 25 consults a
day
and you just get you know you just get
these reps in of reading people
gauging tonality and seeing where you
need to lean in and where you need to
lean back
and so um you know over time i then
started training sales people and sales
managers i had a remote sales team we
fly we'd fly out and do turn arounds um
like in person so i had eight guys we'd
fly out to eight facilities every month
and we turn these facilities around
because i know mike you're in the
fitness world before this
um and then i brought that sales team
in-house and they started doing phone
sales for high ticket so
i've had um i've had in-person phone
high ticket low ticket we've kind of
done
a lot of those things i trained mortgage
leads teams so kind of the whole gambit
and there's definitely some things that
i've seen you know i've brought every
sales product on the market i bought
grant stuff about balfour stuff
um and i think there's a lot of merit
and there's a lot of good stuff out
there
but in my experience uh simplicity is
with scales
and so i'll give you if you're okay with
it i'll give you the few things
that i have implemented consistently
within my companies that have generated
outsized returns
is that cool all right so
what i'm going to do let's rock and roll
all right full jam
so as i said simplicity right i'm the
world's best graphic designer
as you can see here so i'm trying to uh
show the the real keys of the kingdom
so everybody here is everybody here
selling expensive stuff is that most
people on this call
yes everybody's high tech alex fantastic
all right everyone still see me in the
screen
yep all right rock and roll all right so
i'm guessing this guy isn't your first
rodeo
um not your first presentation with sexy
headliner big promise
and so if you have failed for you guys
to uh grow your thing in the past i
promise you it's not your fault lots of
information
very confusing um and you can sometimes
be inundated
with lots of different salespeople's
information you've got mike here who's
a gem and knows his [ __ ] and you guys
are lucky to have him um but
and hopefully in this presentation i
will uh put some of those fierce rest of
like what if i'm never what if i never
make it what if i never turn this corner
um and become the sales person i want
what if i never hit the 100 grand a year
what if i never hit 100 grand a month or
whatever i don't hit the million a month
goal that i have and then what does that
what does that mean about me right if
you've ever thought those things
um like i can tell you i did too um
right after the instance that i had uh
mike with that individual
and that individual drained my entire
bank account and then sent it to their
girlfriend in sweden
and then filed bankruptcy after that
happened i had 1200
because i had sold all my gyms and put
my money into that account so i started
at zero which i'm very grateful for
because it gave me the experience that i
have now and so what i'm going to show
you is that
you can have a simple sales process that
can yield outsized returns a lot of
people like to make this fancy
because it makes it easier to sell stuff
to people about selling
but these are the things that i have
seen that have unlocked the growth for
us because i don't think i'm the best
marketer out there
i think we've simply attached a phone to
a funnel and we've been very efficient
at it
and so as a result of that i've always
been able to make more per customer than
anyone else
because of how efficient we are at the
conversion process all right and so
that's what we're here for
so i want to show you exactly step by
step our process for selling
all right and so there should be uh two
types of people here some of you guys
who are under a hundred thousand dollars
a month
and i'll show you how to never compete
on price again all right and if you guys
are over a hundred thousand dollars a
month i'll show you exactly what we did
to scale a team to get to a million a
month
and beyond is that cool because if
you're under 100 it's just you
right if you're over 100 you need people
all right so it's going to kind of be
like
the actual selling itself and then the
scaling of the sales
all right so that's kind of the goal for
the 60 minutes i'll probably be able to
get it done in 40-ish i'll talk fast so
we can have some time
all right everyone can just listen fast
is that all right all right
about it so i've been really fortunate
um yeah now we're at 105 or 110 or
whatever it is
in selling stuff which has been cool
what's been coolers we've been able to
donate to causes
you guys don't know my story but um i
had a i had a gym teacher after school
who stayed with me
he didn't have to he didn't know me from
anybody and he worked out with me for an
entire year and taught me how to work
out because i was like a really insecure
kid and as a result of that i got into
fitness
and so i feel like it's all of our
opportunity because a lot of you guys
are on here like
we're already in the top one percent in
the world you know what i mean like
we're bitching about not making 100
grand a month
like [ __ ] you you know what i mean like
really and so
um it's been a great privilege to be
able to give back and we've donated 1.4
million just in the last three years
actually 1.7 now i have to update that
um but anyways just the causes that we
that we care about and so for us it's
it's kids being able to have the
opportunity that we had all right and uh
if you guys are in the fitness industry
arnold was my hero is the reason i quit
my job
um and i've been able to you know grow a
friendship with him which has been
awesome
um and we've had you know over a
thousand clients hit a hundred thousand
dollars a year using the sales framework
i'm going to show you all right so like
you can imagine that these people are
not maybe as good as you are
you can imagine that somebody in that
thousand is probably not as naturally
talented
right so the process works okay and
we've got a lot of people over seven
figures now
um but it wasn't that way right so this
is me when i started my first gym
i slept on the floor i had five thousand
dollars total my rent was five thousand
dollars
um and so i had one month that i had to
learn how to make money and uh
i built a funnel because i learned this
from the internet and i was actually i
sent this picture to my dad because i
was so excited
i was so proud of this picture because i
sold that many people in the first
in the first two weeks uh for free
um and things started to grow right that
was my one of my gyms i had nine
employees i felt like a badass
you know my dad finally told me he
thought i you know wasn't a schmuck for
you know being an idiot and getting into
fitness so i thought i felt like i was
figuring things out
and then all of a sudden facebook slap
happened this is years ago there's been
many slaps facebook just kind of
kind of has it's it's [ __ ] hand
proverbially swinging back and forth but
um you know we got slapped and overnight
my lead cost went up 5x right and so my
my money my money making rain turned
into a desert
and the thing was my marketing was
losing money every day and all i could
think about was letting my dad down
and more realistically having my dad be
right
i'm gonna i'm gonna all right cool um
and so the question i asked myself was
like how can i afford to get more leads
right and so i called my friends up and
he had he was a brick and mortar uh gym
owner and he told me
that things were going great for him and
i was like what the hell dude what do
you
what are you doing he was like dude we
just we just attached the phone to the
funnel
and i was like no [ __ ] he's like we're
selling expensive stuff on the front end
now instead of selling trials
i was like well that's cool i'll do that
and so we went from losing two and a
half two to one to making ten to one
return on the front end
right what that meant for my business is
i went from being able to break even at
ten dollars a lead to be able to spend
up a hundred hundred dollars a lead and
still make money
which is crazy right and so then things
started grow again for me
and then we you know open location after
location and things grow
and i met this guy and uh i was i was i
met i joined his mastermind i was trying
to i told him i wanted to create a
nationwide jim
jim chain and he said uh you should
teach other people how you do what you
do
and not grow that chain and i was like
well you make more money than me so
okay i'll listen and so then i started
making um
our doing our marketing system mike this
is by the way at that guy's gym
um i did 191 signups in 19 days and that
was the stack of contracts
um some of you guys may have seen this
it was like the most run ad for like a
year and a half
um but we did a hundred thousand dollars
in 19 days in sales like in the ghetto
all right
so these are the three frameworks sorry
i sped through that because we already
covered a little bit of my story early
so i want to get through it
um and these are the free frameworks
that i kind of discovered um to scale
high ticket all right
and it'll take if you're if you're
partnering someone with someone
then it'll help take their losing
funnels and turn them into into cash
machines and i mean that genuinely
all right so the free three frameworks
that i do is one is the closure
framework all right these are the
questions that get prospects to say yes
all right so adding this to any kind of
any funnel process is gonna instantly
make it more profitable
all right i'm gonna walk through the
questions that we ask and specifically
what only three things that you can say
on a sales call period
it's the number one mistake that all the
sales guys that even my guys make
and i have to remind them of all right
the second thing is the conviction
framework so anyone who believes
can outperform a season sales rep by
simply learning to control their tone
all right so some of you guys right now
can i get a hand i'm
to unshare my screen real quick can i
get hands on the screen of who here is
newer to this
newer to high ticket sales okay great
perfect
then this is for you i'm going to show
you how you can beat the best sales reps
all right and this is how i never ever
hire seasoned closers just fyi
no no it's not like we're going to trade
trading sales people so i don't
um but i'm going to show you how you can
beat season prep season prize all right
which if i can find my presentation
there we go
um by learning control your tone
and the last one is scaling so for all
you guys who are over a hundred thousand
dollars a month and need to scale a team
i'm going to show you how to duplicate
the skill in other people all right
because it's one level of the skill is
learning to sell
another level of the skill is teaching
to sell and it's a more valuable skill
so if you can duplicate your skill in
someone else
that is how you can make 10 times 100
times more money because it's no longer
you're no longer constrained by your
time all right so let's rock and roll
close your framework so after pouring
over like hundreds of scripts like i
mean
hundreds of scripts um i realized that
there was always like these minor
differences in wording
but if i hit these kind of main
milestones along the way i ended up
closing the sale
right and the nice thing is that this
process works for b2c and b2b so i don't
know what stuff you're selling but it
works for both
and it'll work for 500 tickets as much
as 100 000 tickets the process is the
same
all right and the way i teach my sales
teams and now thousands of clients
is this acronym right and like even when
i'm thinking through sales calls we use
we're like
closer c right l so the c is clarify why
the person is on the phone with you
right that's the objective why are you
here why'd you take the time to take the
call
what's the problem right what are we
trying to solve here
after that they were like got it so what
i'm hearing is you're struggling with
this does that sound about right i'm
going to label you with a problem
after that we overview their past paid
so it's like okay so you have this
problem i can't be the first person to
talk to you about this tell me a little
bit about what you've done so far to try
to
try and get past this all right tell me
more about that how that work out for
you
okay understood after that it's like
okay so i'm hearing all these things
this is why you're here this is what
you're trying to get this is what you've
tried and hasn't worked
okay well can i tell you about how i
think we might be able to solve your
problem
this is where we saw the vacation right
and then finally
step before finally we explain away
their concerns so this is where we
tell them about the program and then
we're like do you want to do it they say
yes or no if they say no then we explain
away their concerns so they say yes
and then once they say yes we reinforce
the decision
and this last r here is a point that i
added years later
because we realized that the sale
the sale just continues throughout the
entire customer relationship right
and so for you guys if you're dealing
with clients uh who you're selling for
you have to also sell them on
continuously selling right you might
have closed the card or closed the first
payment
but their onboarding experience they got
to close them again
and then after that when they have their
first week check-in call they got to get
closed again because we have to
consistently sell them
on why they should do anything why
should they not just watch netflix why
should they why should they take action
why should they have the discomfort of
getting
you know smacked on the phone by a
stranger right why should they why
should they feel
the sting of failure we have to sell
them consistently to help them overcome
their pains
right and so i'll show you some of these
more closely so
clarifying why they're there right it's
like what made you come in today what
made you reach out what's your goal
right now why is that important to you
right okay helping me understand what
what are we doing here
right this is one where someone in the
beginning like you have to hit this
because if someone says like you know i
just wanted to find out more information
you're like cool but why like what did
you want the information to solve what
was the
like i'm sure you don't just go around
collecting information all day right
like there's something you're trying to
get out of this
what's the problem and then they and
then you get what you need you're like
got it
okay so just so i'm hearing you right it
sounds like this is your goal
correct then they acknowledge they have
a problem this is important because they
have to say it
they have to own it i can't cure cancer
until you admit that you have it
right we got to give it to you before we
can cure it after that we overview the
past right so it's like what have you
tried so far to accomplish this how long
did you do it for
how long ago how did that work for you
what else have you tried
we call this the pain cycle right we
consistently do this over and over again
so we've exhausted all
options right at that point we have tons
of ammo that we can use later in the
clothes which i'm sure you're aware of
right and the big piece here is we
explain how it's not their fault
because if they had this missing piece
or two of the equation they were halfway
there they were three quarters the way
there they were just missing this one
piece which we're going to provide for
them
right and the nice thing is is for most
of you hopefully you're selling a
a holistic solution right so for example
i'm going to use a fitness example
because mike's from from that background
too
if someone came in and said they've
tried workouts in the past and be like
i'm not telling you don't that you don't
need to work out it's great but you also
need the nutrition and the
accountability right
you need nutrition to make sure they
stop eating [ __ ] because if you just
start working on eating donuts it's not
going to work right
of course now if i make you the best
plant in the world but you don't follow
it's not going to work either that's why
you need the accountability that's what
i'm here for
and so from that point that's kind of
how you can naturally transition so it's
like i'm hearing these things this is
what you were missing
well do you any how the program works
because i think we might be able to
solve that for you they'll say yes
all right so what we've seen is that
there's three things that make clients
successful
right and at this point this is my
belief is that three things has been
you know unequivocal in most pitches is
that i think it's human brain is that
you can't take more than three
but typically it's like three pillars to
the to the stool or three you know
finishing accountability if i was
selling leads i'd want them to be
you know timely uh you know qualified
and you know uh exclusive right
there'll be three elements to make
without what makes a good lead right
there's always three that you can
usually find when you're selling a
solution and
most times not most times every time
if you're on the phone with the prospect
you always have the upper hand because
they have admitted at the beginning of
this phone call that they have a problem
they have not solved it and so
inherently they're going to be missing
one of the keys they cannot have them
all or they would not be on the phone so
you have a
you you you are in an unlosable
situation
unless you choose to lose it right
unless you choose to lose the frame
and so in this instance it has been my
experience that we use
stories short anecdotal stories to
to break the belief of the prospect
around a topic what's important here is
that we don't get into
uh jargon right we don't get into
technobabble and talking about
the program and the modules and
the the things they're going to do
because all of that
sounds like work and that's not what
they're there for they're there for a
result right
and so instead i would say something
like
with the fitness nutrition
accountability like i said earlier so if
i was trying to explain accountability
i'd be like
listen you don't have accountability
when you were a kid you ever like have
your parents tell you to brush your
teeth
they were like yeah like you know you're
like i don't want to i don't want to and
they would tell you oh no you got to go
brush your teeth and you go you brush
your teeth you
sulk back to bed and next night you do
the same thing they say brush your teeth
you go first you
go back to bed but you're an adult now
right you brush your teeth
they're like yeah and that's because you
had external accountability that turned
into an internal habit
right and that's what we're going to do
for you here right so i didn't tell them
about
[ __ ] the coaching call that they're
going to have and the post that they're
going to have and the blah blah blah
we told them as the result of that we
gave them an anecdotal story that made
sense to them
that's probably a really key point i
just want to drive home here is that
when you have your pitch part
it shouldn't be longer than three
minutes like tops
because no one really gives a [ __ ] and
at the end of the day the reason they're
gonna buy
is gonna be because of how understood
they feel
so how much when you went through that
overview of the pain
you were able to restate back to them
accurately
exactly how they felt and the struggles
they are experiencing
which is why you need to shut the [ __ ]
up when they're talking
right and so there's only three things
that are ever said on a sales call do
you guys know what they are
there's only three things that ever come
out of your mouth
questions restatements
and anecdotal stories which is the story
that i just referenced the three stories
that
you will use to break a belief that's it
so this
that's how you sell them the vacations
you have these little sound bites right
i'll give you another example so if i
was doing um if i was doing
food right i'm like listen uh three
parts of the program finish your shirt
accountability so nutrition wise
you've got to eat stuff that's gonna
make you lose weight can we agree on
that
yes okay cool but the problem is you
don't want to do that right that's why
we're here
right right okay so let me ask you a
question
when uh do you feel like what's your
favorite tv show they're gonna be like
uh whatever game of thrones you're like
okay game of thrones
do you feel like you need to get like
motivated to watch game of thrones like
man
i was trying to watch it tonight but i
just couldn't you know i just i just i
got really busy and i just couldn't sit
down on the couch and turn the tv on i
couldn't do it right
of course not because you look forward
to it because you wanted to do it
and the key that we're going to do here
is we're going to get you to look
forward
to the foods that you're eating because
if you look forward to you don't need to
be motivated because you do it on your
own because you like it
does that make sense right so
what i didn't talk about the macros and
the carb cycling and the intermittent
fasting and the calorie counting and the
blah blah blah because the end of the
day that does not matter
what they want is for them to solve the
problem
and have it be pain-free right and
that's what we're explaining to them so
that's selling the vacation right
and this is a saying that i've used for
a long time which is cellification not
the plane flight right
and so this is what everyone else talks
about they're like sir
for us to get you these results you're
gonna have to take your pants off you're
gonna have to jump through this loop
you're gonna have to go through the tsa
the airport lines pack your suitcases
take your shoes off do the layovers
connect your flights
uh have a person farting next to you
don't worry they don't have covet you'll
have tourbillons probably on the plane
then as soon as you're out you think
you're done you stop the way to baggage
claim they probably lost your bag
right and in our world it's your modules
your meal plan your macros your workouts
your support team your urls your domains
your funnels you're targeting your ads
and the other [ __ ] that doesn't matter
right but instead
what they want is you sell maui final
destination and you always sell the same
thing because
the difference is only the level of
service and how they want to get there
right if you have multiple levels of
service so do they want to swim to maui
to where they're trying to go
they're sharks and you could drown or
get robbed
right like this chick crazy uh do they
want to take a boat to maui it'll take a
little longer
there's no shark attacks but there's
still no wi-fi and you're kind of you
know in the sun
do you want to take a normal flight to
maui get there a little faster still
smells bad has security bad food but
you're going to get there
or do you take a private jets in maui
right direct non-stop champagne on the
plane suitcase is packed when you arrive
right and so that's the selling piece
e is explaining away their concerns and
so these are the questions that sound
like um
so there's i'm sure mike has already
taught you a lot of the uh the obstacle
overcome
concepts right so fundamentally there's
three big ones right
price and rather than teach you like the
uh the
the drilling of the obstacles i told you
there's two things you need to memorize
one of them are the stories the second
are the obstacle overcomes
right because those are the things that
you're in the red zone like that's not
where you start thinking about what
you're gonna say
all right so the two things that you
need to memorize as a salesperson
are the stories about what you sell
and the obstacles that you're going to
encounter when you're in the red zone
the questions on the front end you need
to know the milestones you need to hit
in order to move forward and this is one
of the big mistakes i'm sure mike
talks about a lot which is you need to
sit in the pain
if someone does not clarify why they
need a solution
you do not ask for the sale if they're
if we just say hey
you know what what brought you here
today i just want to find out more
information okay cool
so you know let me tell you about the
program like that's not we didn't get
the [ __ ] like we don't know why
they're there
we don't know what their goals are like
one of the things drives me nuts about
my team sometimes is i'm like
dude we're eight minutes in the
conversation i was like i don't know how
many clients they have i don't know what
their revenue is i don't know what their
profit is i don't know what their
biggest pain and struggle was right now
i'm like
what are you doing i'm like you just
told them they're like oh gym launches
100 million dollar company
i'm like they don't give a [ __ ] but they
do my sales guys because they get their
egos puffed up
right but has nothing to do with the
prospect they do not care right they
only care about them
so right right yeah
the issue right everyone talks way too
much about the product
and so when you're training sales people
you don't train them on the product
you train them on the prospect
the product doesn't matter i mean it
matters obviously from like how you're
going to make money because you have to
do a good job
because i'm going to get that in the
second point but in terms of when you
are
selling and training someone if you guys
know someone or know a
specific niche really well then you will
know their pains and if you have a new
salesperson
you hear them say [ __ ] and you're like
that's not what he thinks what is he
doing
he might know the product perfectly but
he just said that the guy's problem was
not the problem
and so then it doesn't matter what the
product is because he doesn't feel like
it's for him
even though it's totally for him but you
just misarticulated the problem
that's where the clarity has to happen
if you nail that the rest of the pitch
is easy
all right and so the key here is relying
on past agreements that have already
been made
so this person with their partner with
their spouse with their business you
know whatever
has ar that person knows that there's a
problem
and they also don't approve of that
problem and so why would they be
in any way against remedying a problem
that they already don't approve of
right and then finally we always tack on
sometimes it's better as for forgiveness
than permission right hahaha depends on
the ticket sale
right but you can get those in right and
then obviously last
last case here is you just do a delayed
close and say let's get your card down
we could put a down payment we can pay
the rest on friday and if between now
and then you know
your partner comes back and says no man
i want to be poor i want to keep
struggling
and like i want to never make money and
like continue to do this for the rest of
our lives then i'll absolutely tear up
the contract don't worry about it
right finally you've got stalls right i
need to think about it
so these are because people don't people
are afraid of making mistakes
right people are afraid of making
mistakes and
because of that they don't like making
decisions because it's easier to let
life make the decision for you and so
they like doing it that way
because then they feel like it's not
their fault right
and so i mean a great obstacle for this
is what's your main concern which is
usually my number one thing i go to when
someone's like
you think about it's like totally what's
your main concern right let's think
about it together
right and so fundamentally these are the
things that they need to know
do you feel like what we're doing can
meet your needs and solve the problem
yes or no yes do you want to work with
us
as a company do you like our values do
you like what we stand for do you
believe what we believe about the world
yes do you have access to funds or know
someone who does
yes well then let's rock and roll
because those are the only things
we know to me to make the decision right
do you like the product
do you like us and do you have the money
to do it that's it
simple as that right and so when we walk
through those if you encounter
these situations obviously there's you
know if you're going to do it now sooner
or
they don't see the value later you
didn't articulate it they have an
objection on decision maker usually
because you [ __ ] something up earlier
in the sale but at this point you're in
the red zone so you got to deal with it
so you rely on past agreements if they
come with a stall then you help them
confront a decision and make a logical
choice
and teach them how to make a decision
that in that moment you say what are you
most afraid of
happening i'm afraid you just you're
afraid of me taking the money right just
taking your money and you getting
nothing right again
well let me tell you how that's not
going to happen right you can bring
their concerns all right then finally
they say yes and you're like awesome and
this is where if you're selling for
someone else
get them to send a personalized video
like hey johnny saw you just signed up
with us today
super pumped to have you uh you're gonna
be meeting with heather tomorrow she's
gonna get you kicked off
um you should in the mail get a special
gift so keep look out for that
and then uh you know send a handwritten
card if someone just bought a really
expensive thing
people are making their decision about
whether they believe in you as a company
within the first 48 hours after the sale
they make a decision of whether or not
they're going to be with you in the long
term
and how they are treated in the first 48
hours after they give you money
so it's critical and it's usually in
that point that people [ __ ] up and just
ignore them
framework two and you know mike i can
stop i'll just do framework two and then
we can do the q a
because if i don't have time to scale
the sales teams i can hit on the points
later um
so this is a big one for everyone who is
who's newer to sales all right
if you believe you can outperform the
season sales rep by learning control
your tone
all right and so i reworked all of our
scripts into the closer framework and
the thing is
immediately some people were crushing it
right while others were still not
selling [ __ ]
and i was like what the [ __ ] right so i
talked to my friends and they were like
dude you should read this book by jordan
buffer
and the biggest thing that i got from
the book was just he was very specific
about tonality
and that was a big shift for me and just
learning
to teach how to ask the question not
just
asking the question right and so
in the book he talks about having the
same issue that i had with scaling sales
like i give the script to two guys some
guy crushes some guys i'm like what the
[ __ ] right
and the thing is there's a hidden
dialogue that the sales team does not
know that they are talking it
right and so the words are not going to
be enough
all right they're just literally ten
percent so the words that you have
it might be the most tested script in
the world it's still only ten percent
ninety percent is how you say the words
right
because how you say what you say is
tonality like right now i can give
everyone hears
you know jerry seinfeld stand up script
you could read it
it wouldn't be funny right because it's
not just that you had the script
it's how you deliver it right and that
takes time to develop
right and that's kind of unconscious
mastery and so there's two ways to do
this
all right that i have found you can
either trick yourself into it or you can
train yourself to do it
all right and since we don't have enough
time
to uh to train on the influence of
tonalities here's the trick that i teach
all right conviction will correct your
tone
conviction made real so um let me tell
you this story
so i was i was brought in to do a day of
consulting for this mortgage leads
company to train their sales team
and the first half of the day i reworked
the whole script i put the closure
framework made it a question-based
um sale and then i came in and they were
expecting me to like rain you know
fire and brimstone on these guys and so
i sat down and i was like who's the guy
you having trouble there was this guy
john so i was like john
and they were selling leads i was like
john i'll go to the leads
he was like well you know and i was like
we're good thanks and i was like let me
show you how you would answer it if you
actually believed the leads were good
i was like you'd say like dude these
leads are [ __ ] unbelievable right now
i'm studying for my real estate exam so
i can get in on these leads my aunt
is a realtor and she has more business
that she can handle and i'm sending her
traffic i'm trying to get my
my my brother to do it with me i'm not
sure how long i'm going to work here
because these leads are killing it for
us
right
if you believe in the product you don't
need to have all the sales skills
you'll do it the right way because
you'll actually want to help the person
so that's why the most important part of
the sale is the product
because unless you're a malicious person
like most people here was everyone here
have some level of ethics
on some level like no near just wants to
like take someone's last dollar right so
then
the only way to sell hard because if
you're going to close you've got to sell
hard
the only way to sell hard is to believe
through and through balls to bones when
you look at yourself in the mirror at
night
this is what i talked about mike said in
the very beginning like what happens
when people start hating on you
the only way that i've been able to stay
where we're at in the gym industry mike
knows the amount of hate that i get
right the only women will do that is
that i read
the testimonials the thousand of them
that i have
of gyms who have gone to six figures of
the hundred gyms we've taken to seven
figures
right like i know beyond a shadow of a
doubt that our product works
i also know that if you sign up for a
gym not everyone loses weight
and i'm willing to deal with that i i'm
willing to give everyone
the opportunity to change their life so
here's the tactics around this
re-read testimonials out loud daily in
front of your sales team
all right and if the business that
you're working for doesn't have
testimonials find another business
all right i'm serious you're not gonna
be able to close unless you're
like literally unless you're unethical
you're not gonna be able to close so go
find something that is a good product
because there's plenty of them out there
all right find a good product that you
believe in you see tons of testimonials
and then read those every day in front
of the team all right
second well this is for the business
owners but fix everything you possibly
can about the product
all right and never blame a customer for
lack of success so as much as there are
people
who have not been successful who've used
gym launch i still take
the fact that they were not successful
and i think what could i have done that
would have made the next person like
them successful
and you plug the hole right if you do
that over and over and over and over
again you know
truly at the end of the day when you
look at yourself in the mirror when no
one else is watching
whether or not you truly put the effort
forward that merits the price that you
are charging
right only you can know that and the
thing is is like the reason sales people
get beat up
is because they don't put the work in
and then it grates on their soul
and then eventually they burn out they
burn out not because they can't handle
no but because they can't handle how
they feel about themselves
right and so you have to put the work in
to have the conviction
because that's what's going to get you
through it if you've ever met someone
who's a born-again christian
all right they are convicted they do not
care how many people tell them to shove
it because they are trying to save
people's souls
it's real like if you let that hit you
it's real you know what i mean
and if you can be a disciple of whatever
the product that you have an evangelist
in the truest terms then all the
scripting stuff
it won't matter why are some of the best
sales people clients who had success
because they believe in it
that's it and the most convicted person
will always
win the fight right they'll always lead
the dance
because they have conviction in their
skepticism you have conviction in your
product and one of you is going to win
out
right and it's the question is whose
belief is stronger because belief isn't
binary
it's not do i believe or do i not
believe it's how much do i believe to
what extent do i believe
would i bet a thousand dollars on this
product or about 10 000
on this product would i sell my mother
this product
think about it if you would sell your
mother this product
how convicted are you probably very
and you will have no problem closing
deals and notice that i have a lower
tone right now so that you listen to the
words that i'm saying so you think that
they're important
in terms of uh the training schedule 60
minutes a day five days a week my guys
do world-class sales training they text
me in the morning before they wake up
they text me once they're done uh they
do the first 25 minutes they read the
script out loud
five minutes they draw obstacles i need
to think about it i need to talk to my
partner
um this is expensive and then they talk
they draw the second half right as a
closer you got to talk you got to listen
you got to train both skills
all right the talking's the tone and
saying the words the right way and the
right sequence without having to think
about it
the listening is going over recording
and figuring out what went right
what went wrong and what we're going to
do next time and saying it
drilling it as a team marking it and
moving to the next one
that's the short answer i appreciate
that and i love the conviction by the
way i can tell that this isn't scripted
or anything and you're just going like
your full heart out there yeah so i'm on
instagram at appromozy
my youtube is alex ramosey my podcast if
you just type in alex mosey
i've got a book some power yeah
if you guys want i've got a book called
alex's alex's book.com
um it has 35 pages of obstacle overcomes
in the appendix
for each one of those obstacles if you
guys want to go grab that there's i
think there's a
there's a sales training in there for
like 100 bucks too if you want to grab
it you can grab it it's very good
[Music]
i do it because i know it's so good
people buy other [ __ ] so it's worth the
money
um hell yeah alex thank you bro thank
you